Musik Hi, Prinz, motherfucking, Kroalperdo Bordo. Hallo. Hey. Okay, herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO mit... IPU, Das Podcast. Stefan und Florian. Schön, dass du da bist. Und unser fantastischer Intro-Komponist Silas beantwortet uns die Frage, was passiert, wenn man Funk mit Todesschreien mischt. Er hat es herausgefunden, vielen, vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro, dass uns... Du moderierst mich an mit einem Todesschrei, muss man auch mal sagen. Ja. Es katapultiert uns in die Folge, wolltest du das sagen? Glaubst du, Leute schreien wirklich, wenn sie sterben? Ich denke, das ist immer völlig albern, wenn jemand getroffen wird von einem Pfeil und dann so zu Boden geht. Also nach meinen spontanen Reaktionen, wenn ich mich erschrecke, zu urteilen, nein. Wenn ich mich erschrecke, mache ich, oder what the fuck, what the ... Was soll da ... Nee, meistens Jesus. Ein deutsch ausgesprochenes Jesus. Jesus. Jesus. Jesus Christus. Nee, glaube ich auch nicht. Aber vielleicht haben Leute das Bedürfnis, zu schreien. Ich glaube schon, dass wenn du angeschossen wirst, dann denkst du, jetzt muss ich schreien. Das ist ja so ein bisschen wie wenn du in der Achterbahn bist. Am Hang. Niemand weiß genau, warum. Am Hang? Am Hang, ja. Du meinst die erste steile Abfahrt? Ja gut, der Rollercoaster-Experte Stefan Koster ist natürlich da, hat die Fachbegriffe dabei. Sorry, da bin ich nicht in der Lingo drin. Die erste steile Abfahrt, das ist mein Fachbegriff, richtig. Aber da schreien Leute auch, ohne genau zu wissen warum. Das fühlt sich einfach vor. Nee, ist gelernt. Auch die Arme hochmachen ist gelernt. Ist nicht Spaß haben generell gelernt? Dass man sagt, so ein bisschen wie, wenn der Fernseher lacht, lachen alle mit, so ein bisschen garnitioniert durch Friends. Ja, ist glaube ich alles einigermaßen gelernt. Du bist so unzufrieden mit deinem Mikrofon. Du bist so unzufrieden, man merkt es richtig. Ich glaube auch, wir werden sabotiert, seit ein paar Folgen, denke ich das, weil in diesem Raum, wo wir aufnehmen, da fehlen immer wieder neue Dinge. So, und es geht bei mir schon so, durch meinen Detektiv-Conan-Vergangenheit gehen bei mir so ein paar Detektiv-Lampen an, um in der Detektiv-Lingo direkt mal um sich zu schiessen. Also meine Detektiv-Lampen leuchten hell, weil erst mal, es fehlte schon mal ein Mikro, irgendwann fehlten zwei Mikros und die sind ja auch teuer. Da steht sehr viel Geld drin, nicht von uns, aber von anderen Leuten. So, und jetzt fehlte auch noch ein Popschutz. Heißt, ich versuche mich schon, wie ihr merkt, seit der Anmoderation um den Buchstaben P herumzumoderieren mit schwitzendem Kopf. Ja, alle Aufnahmeprofis werden wissen, bei PTK atmet man automatisch auch explosiv auf, explosiv laute und deswegen braucht man unbedingt dieses Halte-Stoffetzen vor dem Mikrofon.
Den sogenannten Pop-Schutz, genau.
Den sogenannten Pop-Schutz, den Stefan Tietze heute ersetzt hat durch einen, finde ich, sehr geschmackvollen Pastellrosa-Servietten-Aufsatz.
Es ist eine Serviette, die habe ich jetzt hier rumgeschmissen und es ist die Frage, ob das hält oder ob es wahnsinnig nervt und kratzig ist, ob es die grosse Kratzeis-Drei-Folge in die Geschichte eingeht, weiß ich jetzt nicht, mal gucken.
Es kann sein, dass wir deine Spur komplett ersetzen müssen, entweder durch so Pinguin-Geräusche oder durch Stefan von vorigen Folgen. Ja, oder ich selbst, der nochmal alles nachher einspricht, wie wir, machen wir uns das vor, nicht zum ersten Mal machen würden dann. Nee, du musst deine Spur nochmal neu ansprechen und dann löscht du aus Versehen meine und dann muss ich meine auch nochmal
reinsprechen und dann haben wir zwei sehr
gekünstelte Folgen. Aber ich glaube
da ja an die KI. Ich glaube,
wenn du jemandem alle Folgen speist
als Input, kannst du auch eine neue
Stefan-Spur generieren und eigentlich
gibt es irgendwann so einen Sweep-Spot.
Man muss nur 500 Podcast-Folgen machen
und dann hat die KI genug Futter, um die nächsten 100 selber zu machen. Und zwar, es gibt nämlich so einen ganz coolen Textgenerator jetzt. Und zwar füttern wir, jetzt bräuchten wir mal eure Hilfe. Wir müssen langfristig, lass uns lieber sagen, kurzfristig, alle Folgen transkribieren. Dann können wir die Folgen, und da brauchen wir ernsthaft, ein paar gibt's ja schon in der Puffopedia. Vielleicht reichen die sogar schon aus, müssen wir mal schauen. Aber das machen wir wirklich. Das ist eine coole Idee für die nächsten zehn Folgen irgendwann. Und zwar speisen wir dann mit so eine KI, und die lernt daraus, wie wir sprechen, und dann soll die uns eineinhalb Stunden Skript schreiben, und wir würden das einfach eins zu eins so einsprechen. Ja, oder bestenfalls würde das Skript dann auch noch eingesprochen werden von einer KI, die mit unseren Stimmen gefüttert ist. Aber das können wir noch selber machen. Noch können wir selber machen? Das hat diese Woche nichts mehr zu tun. Ich würde auch gerne einfach mit dir ein bisschen Zeit verbringen. Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin sehr beschäftigt gerade. Es passiert viel. Ja, du bist ein Geschäftsmann. Ich kam ja auch gerade in den Raum rein und er saß dann hier mit so einer, äh, jetzt ist was hier eigentlich abgerade, holy shit. Es war ein lächerliches... Wann mal So viel zu dem Geschäftsmann. Jo, kein Problem. Ist es denn noch da irgendwo? Es geht um den Popschutz. Der Tonmeister Kai wurde hier angerufen. Ja, wir sind gerade in der Aufnahme. Okay, dann komme ich kurz noch hoch. Als erster Notfallkontakt zum Thema Popschutz. Immer wenn hier Equipment verloren geht, dann muss das Kai gemeldet werden. Ja, das kriegen wir schon irgendwie hin. Der hat uns auch schon oft ins Gewissen geredet, weil wir tatsächlich manchmal hier die Sachen nicht richtig aufräumen und die Kabel nicht richtig aufrollen. Und dann ist Kai sehr wütend und redet uns richtig ins Gewissen. Das ist eine sehr, sehr gemütliche Seele, aber der kann auch richtig laut und deutlich werden und einem die Leviten lesen, was man gar nicht denkt.
Detektiv Conan macht die Detektivlampen wieder aus.
Es ist schon mal passiert, dass jemand ein Saxophonist zu einem Gig aufgetaucht ist und gesagt hat,
jetzt habe ich mein Saxophon vergessen und dann gesagt hat, nimm den Regenschirm. Nein, bei dem sind die Detektiv-Kolle-Lampen angegangen und dann hat er gesagt, wo ist mein Saxophon, mein Saxophon ist weg, wer hat mein Saxophon geklaut. Und er dann gesagt hat, nimm einfach den Regenschirm und mach das mit dem Mund, das klingt ähnlich. Und er den ganzen Abend, oder so Esspapier. Esspapier? Stefan, das hatten wir, Esspapier ist kein Instrument.
Erstens, ja, zweitens, Kai war's.
Ich hab den Fall gelöst.
Die unspannendste Folge aller Zeiten.
Ich dachte, wir machen die große Detektiv-Folge jetzt.
Stellt sich raus, nein, Kai hat sich gerade selbst gestellt.
Kai hat das nämlich entwendet, um es für eigene Zwecke zu beachten.
Täter! Täter, Doppelpunkt, Kai. Fall gelöst. Auch Kai. Und jetzt ... Ja, wir haben jetzt noch 20 Minuten in der Folge. Ähm ... Hat Ayumi was, ein Problem? Nein. Lass uns noch mal das Intro spielen. Lass uns das noch mal ein Beispiel. Nur Fragen in meinem Kopf, noch keine Antwort in Sicht. Toll. Detektiv Conan, Detektiv Conan ist ein Fall und er hat keine Ahnung, wer ist Skateboard, Fussball, Gürtel mit Stimminitator, das macht kein Sinn. Die 80 Prozent der Hörer, die keinen fucking Plan haben, wer Detective Collins haben jetzt nichts Problem. Du bist bad, du bist böse, du bist schlecht, du bist böse. Nee, wirklich, guckt euch Detective Conan an. Oder lest die lustigen Anime-Bücher, Mangas, von hinten nach vorne. Allein deswegen schon lustig. Habe ich tatsächlich auch gelesen. Ich weiß noch, damals war ich einer der ersten Kinder bei uns in der Schule, die so ein Manga dabei hatten.
Immer ein bisschen anders, ne? Wollte ich immer gerne ein bisschen anders sein.
Ja, Schulandheim und ich hatte so einen dabei, tatsächlich Detective Conan, Folge 1, wo der in der Achterbahn, da sind wir auch wieder bei der Achterbahn,
Achterbahn, wo du dich wohlfühlst, wo dieser Draht gespannt wurde und dann...
Allen die Köpfe abgesliced wurden? Nein, Komm mal, schau mal. Family Entertainment. Detective Conan sagt, Moment mal, der Einzige, der gestorben ist, war ein Kopf grösser als alle anderen? Ist das vielleicht ein Hinweis? Ich wäre sowas von gestorben. Du wärst gestorben. Wir wussten nicht, dass Stefan Dietze auch noch sich angemeldet hat mit seinem Rollercoaster-Tester-T-Shirt. Klar, Rollercoaster-Tester-T-Shirt. Rollercoaster. Rollercoaster! Und sich auch enthauptet wurde. Ich wurde enthauptet. Deswegen mag ich das auch nicht gerne Achterbahnfahren, weil ich immer die Angst habe, dass es nicht für meine Größe ausgelegt ist. Und jetzt war ich ja vor ein paar Folgen erst, nein, schon mittlerweile bestimmt fünfzig her, war ich im Phantasialand ja. Und da war ich einmal in der Achterbahn, muss ich kurz mal zugeben, wo ich ein bisschen zu gross für war. Da ist immer das Männchen, was einem zeigt, wie gross man sein muss. Ja. Aber bei mir, was die meisten dann übersehen, ist nämlich, es gibt auch eine Maximalhöhe. Und die ist meistens bei 1,95. Also das heißt, die sagen, ab hier ist gut und Maximalhöhe ist dann so, nee, ganz im Ernst, wirklich, dir fliegt der Kopf ab. Nee, genau, wir haben halt, ab und zu fliegt man halt so ganz schmal nur unter so Stahlträgern her und wenn du die Arme hoch machst, aber dann denke ich mir, alle machen die Arme hoch, wo wir gerade, bei wann das gelernt ist, ist ja nicht lustiger. Stimmt, man muss ja dazu sagen, du bist recht gross, was die Körpergröße angeht, aber dafür hast du sehr kurze Arme. Stimmelarmchen. Also du bist, wenn du die Arme hochhebst, eigentlich genauso gross wie normalgrosse Menschen. Das heißt, es gleicht sich wieder so ein bisschen aus. Ja, kurz mal ein Funfact zu diesem Witz, kleine Fußnote, Funfact-Fußnote. PDF ausgehändigt, ausgedrucktes PDF ausgehändigt? Nein, weil der goldene Schnitt, es gibt den goldenen Schnitt, wenn man die Arme spreizt in beide Richtungen, wie ein anmutiger Adler oder eine Ende, dann ist man genauso groß von links nach rechts wie von oben nach unten. Also wenn ich meine Arme spreize und nach rechts und links ausstrecke, ist es auch 1,97 m groß. Warum misst man dann so nicht die Körpergrösse? Ist das nicht viel einfacher? Das ist genau so schwierig, glaube ich. Wenn du so ein Maßband in die eine Hand nimmst, mit den Fingern, und dann einmal so komplett die Spannweite misst. Dann brauchst du zwei Menschen für. Aber ist es wirklich immer so? Ja. Außer bei Menschen, die kürzere Arme haben. Deswegen dachte ich gerade, kann ja nicht sein. Das ist der goldene Schnitt. Ich glaube, der würde nicht goldener Schnitt heißen, wenn es sich immer so wäre. Aber ist es Zufall oder hat das einen Sinn? Ist es so, dass man ursprünglich, weil ich glaube, ursprünglich, man sagt ja, oh, das Besondere an Menschen ist, dass er auf zwei Beinen läuft, hu hu hu, aber es kann ja auch sein, dass eigentlich ... Was ist das Zitat? Hu hu hu? Ich glaube, Richard Dawkins war das oder sowas in der Richtung. Nein, Uhu hat das gesagt. Charles Darwin, ja. Sein Assistenz-Uhu hat das gesagt. Sein Assistenz-Uhu. Also nicht das mit hier nicht gemeint, wirklich. Das Geräusch, was ich mache. Eureka, uhu. Du siehst ja gut aus, uhu. Nee, wirklich, du siehst wirklich gut aus. Uhu. Ich glaube, dass ursprünglich die Idee war, dass Menschen vielleicht gar nicht auf zwei Beinen laufen, sondern so Rad schlagen. Weil wenn die genauso breit sind wie hoch, wenn sie die Arme spreizen, dann würde es sich ja anbieten, eigentlich sich eher per Rad schlagen. Wie so ein Rhönrad, nur ohne das Rhönrad. Genau, ohne Rhön. Das Rhön war immer der Fehler, da sind wir falsch abgewogen. Das habe ich lustigerweise immer schon gesagt. Im anderen Kontext habe ich immer gesagt, das Rhön ist das Problem. Das Rad war immer gut, aber das Rhön war das Problem. Wenn wir das einfach rausgeschneiden würden aus der Geschichte, super. Voll super. Ja, anderer Funfact, Körperfunfact, wir entdecken unseren Körper. Die Elle, also von der Elle bis zum Handknöchel, ist genauso groß wie unser Fuss. Das heißt, warum kann man nicht im Schuhladen, statt sich die Schuhe anzuziehen, sie einfach an die Elle halten? Das ist tatsächlich besser, ja. Das mache ich auch manchmal. Das spart so viel Zeit. Ich habe in meinem Leben hunderte Stunden verschwendet, damit diese dummen Schuhe anzuziehen. Das ist auch immer anstrengend. Schuhe kaufen, das macht man auch nicht. Mit diesen komischen Spiegeln, diese ganz kleinen Spiegeln, die auf dem Boden liegen. Ja, wo in mir wird mich jemand so sehen. Das ist erstens, okay, wenn mir das jetzt gefällt, ich hätte mir auch einfach den Schuh angucken können. Ich sehe den Schuh, ich sehe nicht den Kontext. Wie sieht der Schuh aus für eine Ente? Gut, aber für eine Ente, der man diesen Wetten-das-Tunnelblick-Brillen aufgesetzt hat. Die Ente aus Brocks Boyle wettet, dass sie hundert Menschen an ihren Schuhen erkennt. Enten haben keinen Schatten. Du haust aber heute ein nach dem anderen raus. Ein Tweet, den ich raushauen wollte vor kurzem.
Weil es gibt ja diese Theorie, dass Enten kein Echo haben. Und ich habe das mal, ich habe das in Funfact mal falsch erzählt. Und auch ausserhalb des Kontexts finde ich, Enten haben keinen Schatten. Ja. Das war ein lustiges Erkenntnis. Kann aber wirklich sein. Ich habe jetzt, wusstest du aus dem Kopf heraus, auch nicht, was es ist. Ich hau mal raus. Habe lange nicht mal gemacht in Live-Folgen. Aus gutem Grund, weil du in der Regel zwölf Minuten nach deinem Handy suchst und dabei ganz unangenehm über deinen, sag ich mal, wohlgeformten Podex mit deinen beiden Händen reibst auf der Suche nach deiner Gesäßtasche und dich dabei so lastiv nach vorne beugst, während du dein Handy suchst. Und das ist immer eine ganz unangenehme Atmosphäre, die dann entsteht im Raum, die man auch recht schlecht rauskriegt. Wenn die Luft mal so elektrisiert ist von so einer sexualisierten Szene, kriegst du das auch nicht raus. Kriegt man die nie wieder raus. Enten haben keinen Schappen, mit Punkt oder ohne Punkt? Mit Punkt. Enten haben keinen Schappen. Immer Punkt. Du musst wissen, wann ist der Tweet vorbei, wann darf ich anfangen zu lachen, das ist immer ganz, ganz essentiell. Wie sehnsüchtig er jetzt auf die Anerkennung der Internetwelt starrt und dieser leere Blick, der sagt, bitte mag mich, weil, mag mich, mag mich. Du kannst dich jetzt den Rest der Folge nicht konzentrieren, weil du immer daran denkst, wer hat schon geliked. Ich kann mich nicht mehr konzentrieren jetzt. Ich habe das Handy jetzt aber umgedreht. Mach das auch manchmal, angenommen, du hast einen Crush auf jemanden, oder du wartest auf eine Antwort von einer lieben Person aus deinem näheren Umfeld. Wenn ich dann die Nachricht abschicke, lege ich dann das Handy mit dem Display auf den Tisch, um nicht zu sehen, wann die Antwort kommt, weil ich ja so nervös vor bin. Ja, Ich hab eh immer den Mondmodus an, ich krieg das eh gar nicht mit.
Ich krieg nie bling-plong-bling, deswegen muss das nicht sein.
Aber ich mach oft den Laptop zu.
Wenn ich dann was schreibe, dann schnell Laptop zu.
Und dann Laptop in Müll, Mülleimer in die Mülltonne,
Mülltonne zur Müllabfuhr und dann ist egal.
Und du selbst in den Garten, in den Bunker, in den Prattibunker.
Leiter runter, an so einer Stange runtergerutscht, ganz tief runter, Schlüssel zu und dann schön die Cracker. Und neus canceln den Kopfhörer auch. Und dann die Boxcracker auf, die unendlich lange halten. Und dann kann ich mich vorbereiten. Ja, ein bisschen geht es mir auch so. Warum ist das, das ändert ja nicht dann im Ausgang, aber man will dann doch davor fliehen. Ja, ich glaube, es ist also früher auch so, als man Briefe geschrieben hat, glaube ich, war das ja auch so der schriegste Brief, wenn du denkst, fuck, das habe ich völlig falsch formuliert. Lass uns umziehen, wir ziehen einfach um. Wir ziehen um und sagen es niemandem, und die Person kann dich nie wieder finden. Ich habe ja so alte Briefe gesehen von Beethoven, lustigerweise bei dieser Ausstellung in Wien. Von der zerrst du auch schon seit Jahren. Das ist wirklich eine Content-Grube. Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, wie ich da mit so einer Spitzhacke den Content abschabe. Wirklich, seit Jahren zerre ich darauf. Dieses 12-Euro-Ticket hat sich sowas von gelohnt. Es hat sich so ausgezahlt. Wenn ihr wüsstet, tatsächlich, aber waren ja Briefe ausgestellt, original mit Handschrift von ihm, die hatten keine Emojis. Der hat nicht mal irgendwie Doppelpunkt Klammer zu gemacht, Semikolon Klammer zu, nichts. Aber der hat halt dann so Harre, Harre, Harre geschrieben oder sowas, also das schon ein bisschen Emotion mit reingebracht. Ja, nee, ich frag mich, warum haben die das nicht gemacht? Pfui vielleicht, das kann ich jetzt nicht in die Brerechen springen. Ja, hossa, sowas, pfui, hossa, hurra vielleicht. Ja, hurra, hurra, jawollo. Ja, aber sowas, ja, stimmt schon. Ich glaube, so dieses Lautmalerische, vielleicht hat man da auch noch mehr getrennt zwischen Schreiben und Sprechen. Heute nähert sich das Schreiben ja dem Sprechen an. Ist das so? Wenn du bitte schreibst, b-i-d-d-i. Was machst du? Was machst du? Ja, nix. So, das nähert sich natürlich an. Nee, ehrlich gesagt, es nähert sich nicht an. Wenn man so sprechen würde, was machst du? Nix. Bitte. B-Ü-Loll. Allerschlimmste, B-Ü-D-D-E. Oh, Gott. Ich finde, das Schlimmste ist Joa. J, O, A. Joa. K, U, H, L gab es auch eine Zeit lang. Cool. Aber das ist, ja. Oh Gott. Aber natürlich hat man das gemacht. Na klar, natürlich haben wir alle gemacht. Zum Glück haben wir es nicht in Briefen verewigt, sonst würde irgendwann in 100 Jahren im Stefan-Titze-Museum irgendein Brain-Podcaster, der irgendwie direkt nur noch so im Gehirn ist und so durch Wellen live kommuniziert, so ein Streamer, der zu anderen Gehirnen automatisch live streamt, die so Tabletten genommen haben, wo sie sich die neue Podcast-Folge ziehen können oder sowas. Mehr, mehr Ideen. Und dann in so einem grossen Wassertank leben, wo dann Fische drin schwimmen, die eigentlich dann die Herren sind.
Wie Fische sind die Herren?
Die Fische sind die Herren, die Gehirne sind nur noch so eine Art Spaßfabrik. Für die Fische? Für die Fische, weil die sehr unlustig sind. Unlustigste Tierart der Welt. Und die haben irgendwann gesagt, diese ganze Unterhaltung, die lagern wir aus. So, wir machen extra Gehirne in Töpfen, die haben für uns Spaß und die strömen dann das Dopamin pur an uns ran. Und die Gehirne müssen dann den ganzen Tag irgendwie Flabber schauen. Wie muss ich mir das konkret vorstellen? Also wie sieht das Stefan-Titzen-Museums unter Wasser? Ja. Und da floated so ein Topf mit einem Hirn drin rum. Genau, das Gehirn und das Gehirn, vor dem Gehirn ist so ein Bildschirm mit Flabber und das Gehirn schaut den ganzen Tag Flabber und hat den Spaß seines Lebens. Aber wieso, wegen des Stefan-Tietze-Museums? Ne, ne, ne. Ach so. Das ist nur ein Teil. Die Fische, die in dem Museum arbeiten, die müssen auch versorgt werden. Sind denn auch Fischebesucher in dem Museum? Nein, nein, nein, die gar nicht, die überhaupt nicht. Aber die haben schon ein Museum. Nein, weil, wenn du ein Gehirn bist in dieser Welt, dann musst du jeden Tag einen gewissen Dopamin-Gehalt liefern. Aber wir alle wissen, wenn du Flabber jetzt das hundertste Mal anguckst, selbst Flabber wird irgendwann, jetzt haben wir es verstanden. Das heißt, du musst immer gucken, wie kann ich den Tag füllen mit Flabber, Popcorn, Museum, Achterbahn, du musst so Sachen machen, die die dir Spaß machen, um deine Dopaminen-Grenze zu halten. Und alles, was du über den Dopaminwert dann noch hinaus erfüllst, das kriegst du selber. So, Dopamin ist die Währung in dieser Welt. Geil! Ich hoffe, dass Dopamin halbwegs der richtige Begriff ist, aber versteht, was ich meine. Dopamin ist die Währung ist ein mega geiles Filmprinzip, finde ich jetzt schon. So eine Dystopie, Black Mirror-Folge, Dopamin ist die Währung. Weil es gibt kein Geld mehr, weil alles ist so im Überfluss da, aber die Fische sagen, nee, das nervt, ich will nicht selber den ganzen Tag Flabber angucken, sondern ich habe so eine Dopamin-Flatrate, ich kriege das so rein ins Gehirn und so dumme Gehirne, die verslavt sind, die machen das für mich, das ist halt so das Proletariat in der Welt, die müssen schuften, die müssen den ganzen Tag Dopamin erzeugen. Haben Fische auch Gehirne? Ja, kleine Gehirne. Ja, die haben kleine Gehirne, aber die sind halt randvoll mit Dopamin, weil die die ganzen Tag ballen, die haben eine geile Zeit, die haben eine richtig gute Zeit. Und genau, deswegen gibt es dieses Stefan-Titzen-Museum, da kann man auch rein und so ein bisschen, also wenn man wirklich alles gemacht hat. Also wenn man Flabber hat, hat man dann wirklich schon so dreistellig im fleischigen Bereich gesehen,
dann kommt irgendwann das Stefan-Tiesel-Museum.
Dann sagt man, oh, jetzt haben wir das Jimi Hendricks-Museum,
irgendwie Beethoven-Museum, alle durch,
gibt's noch eins. Und dann hast du so
in so einer Gasse, in so einer schäbigen
Gasse.
Stefan, siehst du, der war das? Ach so, der!
Und da vorstehen so ganz viele aufsachlose Hirne,
die sich so noch anhauen. Hast du ein bisschen D bisschen Dopamin? Hast du ein bisschen Zero oder Dopamin?
Und dann, nee, gut, weg.
Lass uns mal ins Stefan-Tietze-Museum gehen, und da arbeiten dann auch Fische, die dich dann halt rumführen.
Die armen Dinger. Was für Fische?
Die sind traurig, die sind traurig, weil die kriegen kaum Dopamin.
Echt?
Weil die Tickets, die mussten die Tickets ganz billig machen, damit überhaupt noch jemand ins Stefan-Tietze-Museum kommt. Und deswegen verdienen die leider ganz wenig. Aber die haben selber keine Freude mehr an den Exponaten. Aber das Museum sieht doch so aus, als wäre es mal ein krasser Ort gewesen zumindest, oder? Nee, die Exponate, die machen den Fischen, die da arbeiten, auch keine Freude mehr. Die sind fast schon negativ, die saugen, also die deprimieren die schon fast.
Das heißt, die müssen aus anderen Quellen auch noch Dopamin beziehen, um nicht negativ zu werden.
Frage, steile Frage, ist Dopamin nicht schon die Währung?
Aha, nee, ich würde sagen, es ist immer noch der Teuro die Währung.
Der Teuro?
Das ist schon noch die Währung, glaube ich. Was war das denn nochmal? Teuro sind 1000 Euro? Nein, dass der Euro so teuer ist. Das war ein Kampfbegriff damals. Ach ja, ich erinnere mich hier oben. Teuro? Das war diese herrliche Zeit. Das sagen Leute, die auch Teflon sagen. Als der Euro eingeführt wurde, konntest du sagen, alle die Teuro sagen, ah, kann ich von der Liste streichen. Schön von der Liste streichen. Damals war es noch eine händische Liste, auf die man aufgeschrieben hat, wen man mag. Die Papyrusrolle. Ja, genau. Wie jeder weiss, hatte man die grosse Liste, man hoffte immer, dass ich auf deiner Liste stehe. Nee, tust du leider nicht, im Jahre 2000 stand ich noch nicht auf deiner Liste. Nee, ich hatte ja wirklich eine Liste, wo ich hatte in meinem Taschenrechner und Sexualpartnerinnen. Ja, in meinem Taschenrechner hatte ich eine Datei gespeichert hinter Passwort, in wen ich verliebt bin. Habe ich aufgeschrieben. Wiesel, weil es der einzige. Exel aufgeschrieben, für den Fall, dass ich mal vergessen sollte, in wen ich verliebt bin, dass ich dann sage, Moment mal, war da nicht was? Aber jetzt Plot-Twist, als du deinen Autounfall hattest und kurz dein Gedächtnis verloren hast, dachtest du kurz, du heisst mich selber wie die Person. Aber jetzt kommt der Plot-Twist. Irgendwann heirate ich jemanden und dann irgendwann finde ich beim Umzug, genau, wir ziehen um in unser neues riesiges Haus und dann finde ich in der alten Box nochmal meinen alten Taschenreinchen und dann sage, stimmt, da war ja einprogrammiert der Name in das Mädchen, das ich damals in der fünften Klasse verliebt war, wie hieß die nochmal? Und die heißt genauso wie meine Frau. Und es war alles von Anfang an schon angesetzt. Schon angesetzt? Es war schon aufgesetzt. Der Kessel war schon aufgesetzt. Er war schon aufgesetzt. Was? Von Anfang an. Aber was heißt das dann? Und was beginnt dann der Film erst? Oder war das der Film bis dahin? Das ist nach dem Abspann, so der Blooper-Reel. Das ist noch so die Extraszene am Ende des Films sozusagen. Moment mal. Hä? Das ist der große Plotwist am Ende und davor war es ein normaler Josh Clooney. Ja, da vorne ein normaler Rumkommen. Man kommt zusammen und so. Und dann ... Nur, dass es sich für Leute verstehen. Der Twist ist nicht, dass ich das Mädchen geheiratet habe, in das ich in der Grundschule verliebt war, sondern dass sie gleich heisst. Dass sie gleich heisst, okay. Okay, also ... Ja, ja, wow. Da bleibt mir der Popcorn im Hals. Nicht zu viel, der Twist ist nicht so gross. Aber gibt's ja oft, also kann man manchmal sagen, dass man merkt, dass man halt, es gibt ja so Typen, also sagen wir mal so, man merkt irgendwann, stimmt, alle Frauen, die ich verliebt waren, hatten dieses Merkmal und man denkt sich, hm, okay, interessant. Und so kann das ja auch sein, dass man sozusagen den Namen, und das ist dann vielleicht auch der Name der Mutter oder so, das ist ein Sequel.
Ich finde sehr lustig, gerade die Vorstellung, dass Plot-Twists genauso episch aufgemacht sind wie actual Plot-Twists, aber nicht so groß sind. Wie zum Beispiel wenn das Ende von Inception wäre, dass er nicht eine Tochter und einen Sohn hat, sondern zwei Töchter.
Aber es ist genauso episch inszeniert, aber am Ende hat er zwei Töchter und mir fällt alles vom Gesicht. What the? Oder er findet seine Geburtsurkunde. Was, ich heiß Paul? Ich hieß die ganze Zeit Paul? Das habe ich in der Parodie noch nie gesehen, dass so grosse Plot-Twists genauso inszeniert sind, wenn Darth Vader, wenn er sagt, ich bin dein Erzfeind. Und Luke so, nein! Aber er sagt das nicht zu früh, dass es das noch nie gab, denn Dinge gibt es immer wieder. Und so haben wir auch letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass es ... Okay, das ist die sperrigste Überleitung des Podcast-Ufos aller Zeiten, weil das die uncoolste. Schreibt es in die Kommentare. Und so haben wir letzte Woche auch darüber gesprochen. Oh Gott, mit seiner Maus. Er hat eine Maus an seinem Laptop angeschlossen. Das sagt alles aus über dich. Wir haben letzte Woche darüber gesprochen, dass es keine Kussszene zu dritt gibt. Ich rede nicht davon, dass sich drei Menschen lieben und irgendwie einen Dreier haben oder so, sondern ich will, dass sich drei Lippenpaare gleichzeitig treffen. Und du hast mal wieder gelogen. Ich habe euch angelogen, ja. Denn es gibt ein paar Filme, wo sich drei Menschen küssen. Genau. Mal gucken, ob das Internet noch lebt. Ich habe es mir ein bisschen anders vorgestellt. Ach Gott, und wie viele Likes hast du, wie viel Dopamin hast du verdient heute? Ich habe 43 Dopamin verdient. Hast du deine Quote für heute schon erreicht, Stefan? Ich habe mehr Kommentare als Likes. Das war ein gutes Zeichen. Es ist zwar ein bisschen anders, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe. Und zwar, ich dachte wirklich wirklich aus der Vogelperspektive von oben, drei Köpfe kommen sich näher.
Geht das anatomisch überhaupt?
Ja.
Weil der Winkel müsste ja dann ... Also ein Drittel vom Kreis ist ja 120 Grad.
Welcher Winkel hat ein Gesicht?
Ich glaube, das geht. Ich glaube, es geht generell mehr.
Meine Nase wäre, glaube ich, nur im Weg, weil ich tendenziell eine grosse N Nase. Aber hier so Spider-Man zum Beispiel, den könnten zwei Leute gut küssen gleichzeitig. Ja, Spider-Man, so der auf dem Kopfkuss, der ist ja etabliert. Ich sollte mir das raussuchen, das ist echt albern. Mit seinem Mausrad ist er jetzt am Rumradeln durchs Internet. Ah ja, hier. Ring, ring. Hier hat jemand geschrieben, und zwar der Film Oh Beautiful Night, auf Arte verfügbar. Natürlich, aber ein Film, wo sich drei Menschen küssen. Ich würde auch zuerst bei Arte suchen. Bisous-à-trois nennt man das anscheinend, also ein Kuss zu dritt, gibt es anscheinend einen natürlich französischen Begriff dafür. Vielen Dank für den Hinweis, schaut euch den Film an, falls ihr das sehen wollt, aber ansonsten wenig tatsächlich. Also aus der französischen Arthouse-Szene natürlich einiges, aber ansonsten nicht so viel. Aber es stimmt schon, es ist erbärmlich, ich muss eine Maus benutzen und war meine Laptop-Tastatur und mein Trackpack. Das war ein Bild für Götter, ich kam heute in den Raum rein und Florentin saß, sehr geschäftig an seinem Laptöppchen vor ihm aufgeklappt, sämtliche USB-Hubs belegt. Da merkt man auch, da brennt der Kopf schon vor lauter Arbeit und hat eine Maus angeschlossen an seinen Laptop. Und ich finde, das lässt einem immer ein bisschen dusselig wirken. Es lässt einem dusselig wirken. So ein bisschen so, als ob man nicht wirklich zu schätzen weiß, dass der Laptop vor einem schon alles hat. Ja, es ist vor allem... Bewegt es adaptionsfähig. Vor allem, es ist ein albenes Bild, weil ich auch noch eine Tastatur dabei habe. Und der Laptop hat schon eine Tastatur und darunter ist noch eine Tastatur angeschlossen. Du hast ihm alles genommen. Du nimmst die Hälfte des Laptops, den Bildschirm. Das ist wie wenn du so ein Eis am Stiel hast und das löffelst. Ja, den Stiel und den Stiel ableckst. Ja. Oder wenn ein Auto dich fährt.
Wo denkst du auch, Leute, so funktioniert es nicht.
Es ist nämlich so gewesen, dass gestern ...
Gestern ist meine Laptop-Tastatur und mein Trackpad kaputtgegangen.
Geht nicht mehr.
Wie, was war die Situation?
Ich möchte nicht mit meinem Laptop tauschen.
Ich glaube, ich habe einen der bemitleidendsten Werte ...
Bemitleidendsten Werte ...
Bemitleidendsten ...
Stefan, ich schaff das! Ich habe einen der bemitleidenswertesten Laptops der Welt.
Setz dich erst mal.
Kann ich mich kurz hinlegen?
Mir ist es wirklich ein bisschen heißer.
Ich will etwas trinken.
Komm, wir haben es dabei.
Also, du hast einen der bemitleidenswertesten Laptops.
Danke. Danke, das tut gut. Ich trinke echt mal einen Schluck jetzt. Ich trinke viel zu wenig. Mal Hydrierung ist wichtig. Und ich behandle meinen Laptop nämlich nicht gut. Ich behandle ihn wirklich nicht gut. Ich werfe ihn rum. Und das Schlimmste, was ich glaube ich mache mit meinem Laptop ist, ich nehme ihn regelmäßig mit in die Badewanne. Und da glaube ich, hört's auf. Da, ich glaube, es gibt irgendwelche Computerschutzorganisationen, die jetzt aufschreien, die jetzt einen wütenden Brief aufsetzt. Wir werden uns noch, wir werden die Zeit noch vermissen, wo Laptops noch keine Rechte haben. Die CETA, die Computer-ETA, die sich für das Wohlergehen von Computern kümmern. Und was ich immer mache, ich habe ja immer so ein kleines Bügelbrett, das ich über die Badewanne lege und darauf kommt der Laptop. Wir alle wissen, wie du badest. Sprich, ja, ja, ja, wir haben die Bilder gesehen, ich weiß, die Paparazzo haben gute Arbeit geleistet. Paparazzi. Ja, Paparazzos. Die Paparazzos. Und das ist nämlich dann so, weil ich bade, und das gebe ich auch gern zu, ich bade gerne heiß und dadurch entsteht natürlich eine Menge Wasserdampf, der natürlich direkt aufdampft, direkt in den Laptop. In den Laptop rein, sodass er auch quasi schwebt.
Er schwebt quasi, er schlägt an und es ist immer nur eine Frage der Zeit, weil ich, der hat ja so ein Trackpad und natürlich fummel ich da mit den nassen Fingern auch drauf rum.
Und es ist oft so ein Spiel mit der Zeit, dass eine halbe Stunde, nachdem das Bad begonnen hat, der langsam seinen Geist aufgibt und das Trackpad nicht mehr funktioniert und ich dann nur noch in einer Ecke festhänge und der mir ganz klar signalisiert,
Aber und nachdem das Bad begonnen hat, der langsam seinen Geist aufgibt und das Trackpad nicht mehr funktioniert und ich dann nur noch in einer Ecke festhänge und der mir ganz klar signalisiert, aua, aua, aua, aua, ich habe Schmerz. Lass mich, lass mich, lass mich. Lass mich los. So ein Text-Doc geht auf, aua, aua, so Schriftgrösse 16. Das ist schon ernst gemeint. Ja, es ist richtig ernst gemeint. Welche Filmreferenz? Mehr Dampf!
Sehr schlecht nachgemacht.
Mehr Dampf!
Kommt es denn bekannt vor, wenigstens?
Also, ich weiß, deine Imitationen sind immer absolut perfekt.
Deswegen ist es ja noch mies.
Mehr Dampf!
Ich mache einfach Deutsch.
Aber ich will einen, gut, ein Dollar-Tipp, das soll eigentlich ein chinesischer Akzent sein. Mehr Dampf! Boah, so das Wandel der Schloss oder so? Nee, ich hab keine Ahnung. Nee, Fluch der Karibik 3 am Anfang in Singapur. Weißt du, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, man muss bei deinen Filmrätseln gar nicht so viel über die Filmgeschichte wissen, sondern nur wissen, man muss nur wissen, welche Filme du gerne schaust. Habe ich das Gefühl. Du machst jede Woche dieses Filmquiz. Ja, eben. Du machst immer dieses Filmquiz und sagst, in welchem Film spielen 30 Statisten mit Flut der Grimik? Verdammt, du bist gut. Ja, trotzdem schneidest du erstaunlich schlecht ab. Ja, ich verliere jede Woche. Ja. Ich verliere jede Woche in deinem Filmquiz, aber es macht immer Spaß. Aber ganz kurz, sind Laptops nicht dafür gemacht, für diese Härtetests? Gut, ich meine, das ist schon krass, was du da gerade mit deinem Tests machst. Ja, also ich glaube, dieser Wasserdampf, der dann durch die Ritzen geht, ist schon hart, aber... Aber ich finde, wenn man den Laptop gerade so sieht, da hinten, oder auch generell Bildschirme oder Fernseher, guck mal, ich stelle mir mal vor, das ist so ein, wenn der Bildschirm so ein Gesicht ist, und ich finde, die sind so geil altruistisch, Bildschirm und Fernseher sind nur so für dich, die geben dir die ganze Aufmerksamkeit, wenn du dir vorstellst, dass das ein Gesicht ist, und es zeigt dir alles. Die sind so offen und aufgeschlossen und süss. Das Gesichtswinkel 180 Grad. Dein Gesichtswinkel nicht mal 120 Grad. Aber wie süss? Die können sich, ein Monitor können sich nie zu dritt küssen. Never ever. Keine Chance. Keine fucking Chance. Da haben wir doch einen Film. Desktops, Bildschirme, wie Cars nur mit Monitoren, Monitors. Ja, klingt gut. Viele Leute haben Laptop, haben Monitor. Was ist die Story, worum geht's da? Äh, Frau-Laptop, Mann-Laptop, Mann-Laptop. Warum haben Sie einen Ghetto-Blaster dabei? Weil es auch Musical-Part gibt. Okay. Ja, ich glaube, wir melden uns ... Allein die Vorstellung, dass der Typ in der Bahn mit diesem grossen Ghetto-Blaster da hingefahren ist. Seinen Text durchgeht. Seinen Text durchgeht. Ich bin ein Monitor, ich zeig dir, was du sehen willst. Pssst, in der-Bahn. Pssst, ja, Ruhe bitte. Ja, weil die New Yorker U-Bahn zivilisiert ist wie eine Bibliothek. Monitor, Monitor, ich zeig dir, was du immer sehen willst. Das ist gut, das mag ich. Aber es stimmt schon, ich finde auch immer, hatten wir nicht immer mal gesprochen, ob Laptop sitzen oder stehen? Ich glaube, die sitzen... Die sitzen schon. Nee, ich glaube, die knien. Oder? Die knien vor dir. Aber was ist der Bau? Also jetzt, also ich, keine Anekdote aus der Entwicklungsgeschichte von Cars, dem besten Film, den Pixar je gemacht hat. Ja. Erst sollten die Augen die Scheinwerfer vorne sein. Das ist so bescheuert. Das ist so, als ob bei Toy Story nicht in Müntern sprechen. Oder? Ist ein bisschen das Gleiche. Genau, die Augen sind auf dem Hut von Woody. Äh, okay. Und die bewegen sich da und die sind sehr ausdrückvolle Augen.
Alles klar. Und der Mund ist so der Hut, der so zwei Lippen hat.
Bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das funktioniert.
Also ursprünglich, weil wenn man sich ein Auto anguckt, dann hat das ja schon ein Gesicht.
So der, wie sagt man, Grill, kühler Grill oder so als Mund.
Und die Scheinwerfer.
Wir Männer.
Ja, Männer. Yes, brumm, brumm auf der Asphalt. Und dann die, äh, die, die. Brumm, brumm. Die Scheinwerfer sind die Augen, und das war der ursprüngliche Designvorschlag, war von Cars, Cars mit Persönlichkeit, die Scheinwerfer sind die Augen, wir haben gemerkt, nee, das sieht total bescheuert aus, weil die sehen aus wie Schlangen, die haben ja nur so einen ganz kleinen Kopf vorne und der Rest ist so leerer. Super unsüss. Unsüss. Und dann haben sie die Windschutzscheiben zu Augen gemacht. So, ich glaube, es nervt dieses... Und wie... Oh, oh, oh, oh, Stefan zieht seine Rosé-Serviette ab. Ich versuche jetzt den Buchstaben, der unangenehm klingt, einfach wegzulassen. Stefan unplugged. Unplugged. Stefan kabellos. Stefan ist jetzt offroad.
Ich bin kabellos. Er hat keinen Popschutz mehr,
er ist ungeheckt. Kabel ist auch raus.
Er ist ungeschützt. Mal gucken, was passiert.
Macht mehr Spaß, oder? Ungeschützt macht immer mehr Spaß.
So, und dann, jetzt ist die Frage,
wie würden Sie das Character Design
von dem Laptop darstellen? Wo ist da der Kopf,
wo sind die Augen? Ich glaube,
ich finde es gut, wenn die sitzen.
Aber dann ist die Frage, wenn man die zuklappt. Aber wie laufen die dann?
Aber ist nicht dieser aufklappte Zustand?
Sind Laptops, würdest du sagen, häufiger
zu oder häufiger auf? Ich glaube,
ja fast häufiger zu. Nein, meiner ist
häufig offen. Ja? Ja. Und wenn
er so rumstellt bei der Wohnung, dann offen.
Manchmal, wenn ich ganz vorliegt bin, seitlich.
Ah ja, ich auch.
Stelle ich ihn seitlich? Ja, ich stelle ihn auch oft seitlich hin. Jetzt gerade zum Beispiel. Dein Laptop steht seitlich. Warum eigentlich? Warum mache ich das denn zum Beispiel? Das verstehe ich da manchmal nicht. Wahrscheinlich, weil wenn du auf dem Stuhl sitzt, kannst du ihn einfach seitlich auf den Boden stellen, weil du müsstest ja ganz runter auf den Boden greifen, wenn du ihn so nehmen würdest. Ja, aber 90 Grad Winkel und seitlich hinstellen, das ist mein Lifehack des Tages. Okay. Mein Lifehack. Der Lifehack des Tages. Laptops? Nicht der Woche? Ich meine, wir machen eine Folge pro Woche. Wir müssen, wenn wir jetzt sagen, es ist der Lifehack des Tages. Nee, deswegen haben wir heute sieben Lifehacks. Okay. Also, mein erster Lifehack ist Laptops und 90-Grad-Winkel hinstellen, da kann man sie einfach wieder aufheben. Man muss nicht wie so eine Münze immer so knibbeln, bis man sie endlich hoch bekommt. Das ist der Live-Fake für Samstag jetzt. Genau. Okay. Ja, was ist dein Live-Fake für Samstag? Jeder hat einen pro Tag. Es gibt 14 Live-Fakes. Jeder hat einen, mindestens einen pro Tag. Die Top 14, oh, um Gottes Willen, auf gar keinen Fall.
Nee, komm, mach einen, dann ist gut. Habe ich tatsächlich letztens ausprobiert, und zwar hat mich da eine Twitter-Userin darauf hingewiesen, während meines Moin Moins bei Rockabins TV, und zwar der Zimtapfel. Ein schöner, aufgeschnittener Apfel ist eine Mahlzeit, die Freude macht. Ich glaube, man muss sich auch manchmal einfach ein bisschen Zeit nehmen für Genuss. Und klar, ich habe natürlich auch gerne einen Snackapfel, beiß rein, schön Apfel butzen, ist natürlich gut, Bösewichtmoment, irgendwie so, dann so verächtlich wegwerfen. Mehr Wohnung, verächtlich wegwerfen, um dann wieder hinzugehen und dann doch in den Müll zu werfen. Das macht Spaß, aber auch gerne mal einen Apfel aufschneiden und schön raus und dann einfach ein bisschen Zimt drüber streuen, ganz neues Geschmackserlebnis, keine weiteren Hiten. Ganz neues Geschmackserlebnis, ein nie dagewesenes, das wird ein Wortlaut, darauf willst du zitiert, da festgenagelt werden, ein nie dagewesenes, exklusives Geschmackserlebnis.
Könnten wir das Zitat vielleicht nochmal raus?
Ja, okay, so einmal darfst du es noch ändern.
Okay, ein bombastisches Geschmackserlebnis, denn Zimt ist toll, aber nur bombastisch, wenn es ein Granatapfel ist. Wow! Zählen wir jetzt wie viele Leit... Hey, bist du wahnsinnig? Das ist, als würde es dem Hörer direkt ins Ohr schreien. Er hat ohne Schutz, ohne Schutz ins Mikrofon gebrüllt. Entschuldige dich bei all den Leuten, die jetzt von der Straße abgekommen sind und einmal schön in die Leitplanke gefahren sind, weil du ihnen das Ohr gebrüllt hast. Weil sie das Lenkrad auch rumgerissen haben. Tolle Szene, oder? Muss man sagen, in Baby Driver, wo der mit... Ich habe keine Erinnerung an den Film, aufgrund des Erlebnis, was wir immer noch gerne erzählen, weil wir es in einem 8D-Kino gesehen haben und mir die Dimensionen nur so um den Kopf geschossen sind. Wir haben das in New York gesehen, wollten in ein New Yorker Kino und dachten, okay, so ein cooles Arthouse-Schwarz-Weiss-Hitchcock-Kino. Nope, wir waren in einem Space Shuttle, in dem modernsten Kino aller Zeiten. Ja, 5D, wo die Sitze, du wirst hier sind, von Larrys nach rechts und oben nach unten geschüttelt, kriegst Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt und so Luftstöße in den Rücken. Fuhigbar drei Stunden meines Lebens. Ich lache da immer noch drüber. Weil die haben ja diese Funktion, dass dir Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt wird. Und dafür gibt es aber nicht immer gute Szenen im Film. Nicht jeder Film hat Szenen. Und da gibt es eine Szene, wo Baby Driver mit seiner Freundin in den Diner ist. Und dann kommt die Bedienung. Die ruhigste Szene. Ruhigste Szene, nur Dialog. Diese Klassik im Hintergrund, nur Dialog. Und dann kommt die Bedienung und schüttet nochmal Wasser nach und in dem Moment werden allen Kinobesuchern Wasser ins Gesicht gespritzt. Kompletter Schock aus dem Nichts. Er reist einen völlig raus, anstatt ein immersiveres Erlebnis zu kreieren, was ja die Grundidee eigentlich ist. Die Popcorn sind nass. Und denkt sich, mit wem identifiziere ich mich jetzt hier? Bin ich das Glas? Du warst die ganze Zeit das Glas. Glasses. Moment, was? Glasses. Aber das ist auch gut, weil in Baby Driver, also Baby Driver, mittelmässiger Film würde ich insgesamt sagen, aber diese eine Szene finde ich cool, weil er hört ja immer gerne Musik und der Bösewicht irgendwann steht dann mit der Pistole vor ihm, schiesst aber nicht auf ihn, sondern schiesst zweimal an ihm vorbei, direkt an den Ohren, um ihn taub zu machen. Das finde ich genial. Weil stell dir mal, wie viele Millionen Szenen in Filmen gab es schon, wo jemand mit der Pistole auf den anderen zielt. Und es läuft immer gleich ab. Aber da, Twist, und da habe ich gesagt, ja, da habe ich aus Freude gegurgelt, weil es komplett was als Gesicht gespeckt ist.
Und das war toll.
Das war toll.
Wenn ich nur mal sagen, da denke ich auch immer noch dran.
Ich fand auch super, wie sie diesen einen Bösewicht aus dem 20. Stock eines Hochhauses rausschmeissen, er unten aufplatzt und von hinten so ein kleiner Licht, so ein kleiner Luftstoss in den Rücken kommt. Wo man sagt, das ist dann so angesetzt, das Wasserglas, da kriege ich eine Wasserladung, einen Liter ins Gesicht und er fliegt aus dem zwanzigsten Stock und es ist, aber ich war fast froh, weil wenn es genauso übertragen worden wäre, wie wenn Wasserglas gleich Liter Supersplash ins Gesicht ist, was ist dann ein Sprung aus dem zwanzigsten Stock? Ich stelle mir nur vor, der fällt aus dem zwanzigsten Stock und alle stehen schon so auf und haben Angst, was, Hilfe, Hilfe, ducken sich und laufen weg, bevor der auf dem Boden aufbricht. Und diese vier D-Sitze so fallen durch den Boden und platzten auf dem Boden. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es sich durchsetzen wird, aber genauso wie 3D, wo alle dachten, krass, jetzt ist 3D. Du weißt nicht, ob es sich durchsetzen wird? Das war vor fünf Jahren. Ob es sich 3D durchsetzen wird? Nee, diese 4D. Ist das 8D-Kino? Vielleicht ist 9 der Sweetspot, vielleicht reichen 8 Dimensionen noch nicht. Oder wir sagen als Gesellschaft, wir sehen dreidimensional. Vielleicht ist das auch einfach die maximale Anzahl an Dimensionen, die wir brauchen. Hoffentlich ist das nicht, wenn irgendwie interdimensionale Alienwesen, vielleicht kommen die einfach auf so 4D-Sitz angefahren. Und alle so, ich spreche mit Wasserspritzpistolen, mit ihren Drüsen, schießen sie uns ab, wir können nichts dagegen machen.
Wir mit unseren lächerlichen drei Dimensionen, stümperhaft, können nichts dagegen tun.
Ich habe mir mal so eine Videoreihe angeguckt, die einem erklären soll, wie man Dimensionen verstehen kann.
Gab es die Ameise auf dem Blatt Papier?
Mhm. Ja. Die hat auch den Job ihres Lebens, diese Ameise, oder? Die hat ausgesorgt. Weißt du, was da passiert? Immer wenn jemand Dimensionen erklären muss, kommt die Ameise und das Blatt Papier. Ich glaube, die hat mittlerweile ihr eigenes Blatt Papier, das sie mitbringt zu den Drehs und sagt, ich habe mein Blatt Papier dabei. Will jemand vierter Dimension erinnern? Klar, kein Problem. ist es wie ein Blatt, das man so knickt. Ich weiß, ich weiß, das musst du mir nicht erklären. Ich glaube, alle Ameisen lernen das auch in so einer Ameisenschule. Genau wie Polizisten an irgendeinem Punkt Filmpolizisten werden, wissen Ameisen, sie werden irgendwann dafür instrumentalisiert, vier Dimensionen zu erklären. Genau wie Bleistifte irgendwann wissen, dass sie schwarze Löcher erklären und dann quasi so einmal durch so ein Wurmloch,
durch so ein Papier gestiftet werden. Ich glaube auch, dass irgendwie so Lamy oder so Stifthersteller
irgendwie 80 Prozent ihres Umsatzes nur mit Erklärungen
von Wurmlöchern und vierten Dimensionen machen.
Das ist wie ein Blatt Papier, wo man durchsticht.
Gut, alles andere schreibe ich nämlich in mein iPhone rein.
Aber diesen Bleistift brauche ich nur, um Dimensionen zu erklären.
Jetzt weint er.
Ich hätte so gern ein Leben, wo ich Wurmlöcher erklären müsste oder Dimensionen. Was hätten wir für ein cooles Leben, wo wir Stifte bräuchten, um sie durch Papier zu stecken und Wurmlöcher zu stecken. Aber wird es dann nicht auch wieder uncool, wenn du es die ganze Zeit erklären musst? Und auch in Filmen sind die nie fröhlich dabei, es ist immer, also nochmal.
Ja.
Also nochmal, wenn wir von A nach B kommen,
dann können wir nur, wenn der Raum, die Raumzeit
gekrümmt ist.
Die müssen auch so oft erklären,
ich habe letztens auch wieder Tenet
gesehen, keine Chance, weil da gab es
zu wenig Erklärszenen, als wenn
der den Wurmloch erklärt und in so einem
Film wird achtmal Wurmloch erklärt und alle so, einmal noch, kannst du einmal noch erklären und er will die, ey, jetzt leider so, don't try to understand it, feel it. Also, wir haben ganz viele Hinweise bekommen auf ein, ah nee, das ist der falsche Link, nämlich auf eine neue Erkenntnis aus dem Bereich der Dinosaurierforschung. Und ich dachte, wenn wir jetzt gerade eh im Wissenschaftssegment sind, dann kann ich ja hier mal mit meiner ... Dieses Geräusch allein. Dieses billigste Plastik auf Holz. Denn Melissa hat uns geschrieben, stellvertretend für alle wissenschaftsinteressierten Hörer dieses Podcasts und hat uns geschrieben, World's only fossil of T-Rex skin. Nochmal, was? Ich habe das Gefühl, das kam gar nicht an. Das weltweit einzige Fossil von T-Rex haut. Nein. Enthüllt. Nein. Nein. Nein. Nein. Bist du bereit? Ich bin nicht bereit für Fell und ich bin nicht bereit für Federn. Ja, Federn ist man ja davon ausgegangen. Damit hast du dich einigermaßen mit Federn an. Nee, ich habe mich angefreundet bei den Jungtieren. So weit bin ich. Das ist wie so, wenn du so einen Nazi-Opa auf die gute Seite holst. Und es geht ja auch nicht von jetzt auf gleich. Das ist ein Prozess. Und ich bin gerade vom Leugnen bin ich hin schon so, ich akzeptiere dass es genau wie so ein Onkel, der den schwulen Sohn, den schwulen Neffen akzeptiert. Ich habe jetzt akzeptiert, dass Jung T-Rexe Federn hatten. Ja, wie kleine Hühnchen. Aber das verlebt sich. Das verlebt sich. Der findet irgendwann schon den richtigen Weg. Okay. Wie die Natur ihn will. Wir sind bei dir noch nicht am Ziel, aber vielleicht ist der erste Schritt von vielen gemacht. Da bin ich jetzt, okay? Nur das ist Bescheid. Ich respektiere den Schritt, den du gemacht hast, aber wir wissen beide, da geht noch einiges. Also. Warum guckst du mich so an? Man steht da in diesem Text. Das ist nicht so ein langer Text. Also ... World's only fossil of T-Rex skin suggests, it was covered in the same skin as human anus. Das ist nicht so schlecht. Moment, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, ist es nicht so schlecht. Es tut mir wirklich leid. Human Anus, wenn die sich anders formulieren können, warum müssen die das so formulieren? Das ist Science Magazine. Es tut mir leid. Deswegen sagen sie Anus. Weil tatsächlich, ich glaube, der Anus hat dieselbe Haut wie Lippen. Riesenlippen? Also der T-Rex besteht aus riesigen Lippen. Nee, der Anus hat doch so ... Wie ist das Anus? Auf Lippen wächst ja auch keine Haare und so. Das ist halt so eine zarte Haut. Ja, du hattest mich bei keine Haare, also auch keine Federn. Das wissen wir nicht. Nein, ich hab dich ein kleines bisschen geprägt.
Ja, hast mich veräppelt.
Die Überschrift lautet, Skin suggests it was covered in scales, not feathers.
Schuppen!
Was sind Scales?
Schuppen, guck mal, schau dir den Stein an.
Schau den Stein an!
Ja!
Schuppen, aber sehr kleine Schuppen, muss man sagen, oder? Ja, aber das ist ja wie meine Steiftiere. Ja. Schau den Stein an. Ja. Schuppen, aber sehr kleine Schuppen, muss man sagen, oder? Ja, aber das ist ja wie meine Steiftiere. Ja. Das ist ja wie meine Steiftiere, so porenhaftig. Es sind sehr kleine Schuppen, also es ist nicht so, wie man sich so einen Drachen vorstellt, mit so richtig kräftigen, grossen Schuppen, sondern eher so wie so eine Handtasche ein bisschen. Also wie so eine Paillette, also wie Pailletten. Oder wie so ein Alligator. Nee, eher wie Pailletten. Nee, nicht wie Pailletten. Doch, ein bisschen. Also die haben die gleiche Grösse wie eine Paillette. Ich mag das nicht, dass du das Wort sagst. Also im Grunde, also der wissenschaftliche Stand ist, T-Rex hat ein Pailletten. Also ich übersetze das mal in profane Sprache. Gibt es da Hinweise auf die Farbe? Also, wenn es jetzt transparente Glitzerpailletten sind. Ja, es heißt hier Colorful Shimmering Scales. Nicht im Ernst. Doch. Colorful Shimmering. Also, ich stell mir das ein bisschen vor wie so eine Schlange, die ja teilweise auch so eine frisch gehäultete Schlange. Es ist von der Onkel akzeptiert seinen schwulen Neffen, lustigerweise wirklich so geworden.
Shimmering Scales.
Ja, Colorful Shimmering Scales.
Vielleicht waren die so super flamboyant, hatten so bunte, wie so Paillettenkleider an.
Also ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen wie Twilight Vampire in der Sonne meets frisch gehäutete Schlange
meets Anus. Kannst du da
was mit
Leben oder müssen wir da jetzt Einspruch
erheben?
Wollen wir wieder einen Brief schreiben? Wir schreiben einen Brief, okay?
Du siehst sehr unglücklich.
Wie heißt die Website? Wir schreiben wieder einen Brief.
Die heißt melissa.de
Nein, es ist sciencemag.org
.org
Das tut mir leid,
aber es ist eine .org.
.org ist meistens seriös.
Von Carolyn Gramling.
Gramling?
Ja gut, dass Frau Gramling
die Dinosaurier verunglimpfen will,
das ist mir schon noch klar. Und zwar, Melissa
ist up to date, denn der Artikel
stammt von 2017.
Also Melissa ist
vier Jahre in der Vergangenheit
unterwegs. Ja, aber das ist ja okay, weil
Die Melissa ist up to date, denn der Artikel stammt von 2017. Also Melissa ist vier Jahre in der Vergangenheit unterwegs. Ja, aber das ist ja okay, weil ich war ja in dem aktuellsten Dinosauriermuseum in New York. Wann war man da? Das war doch voll. Meine fucking Güte, können die sich nicht endlich mal entscheiden? Da hieß es ja Federn. Ja, aber bei den jungen Vögeln, wobei der hat ja schon auch Paillettenhaut. Jetzt will ich drüber nachdenken, hat er schon shimmering colorful Paillettenhaut. Ich halte das alles für einen grossen Hops. Es tut mir echt leid, Stefan, aber irgendwie. Die sollen das mal malen. Dass die sich auch nicht einigen können auf irgendwas. Ich meine, was ist mit dem Bär? Seit tausenden Jahren hat der Bärenfell und nicht erst Pailletten, dann Haut. Dann Rusters. Der sieht einfach immer schon Bärenartig aus. Dann irgendwie so ein Hornpanzer, wie eine Schildkröte. Dann der Strohhut. Was war da los? Nein! Bären sind Bären. Ja, Bären sind Bären sind Bären. Das geht einfach seit Hunderten von Jahren. Dinosaurier haben viel länger gelebt, als wir jemals wahrscheinlich existieren werden. Ist dir klar? Ob dir das klar ist? Sagt wer, wenn Miss Grambling das nicht sagt, glaube ich das nicht. Science-Mag.com Ja, aber vielen Dank an Melissa für diesen Hinweis, Dinosaurier-Fakten sind immer gern zu haben, auch wenn es mittlerweile, ich will nicht sagen nervt, aber schon irritiert, dass die Wissenschaft sich da nicht einfach festlegen kann und einfach sagt, Leute, das ist ein grosser Molch.
Ein T-Rex war ein grosser Molch.
Mulch. Es war ein
Mulch. Sorry?
Es war ein grosser
Molch. Ja, jetzt lese ich, jetzt
sehe ich es auch.
Ich muss kurz telefonieren.
Grosser.
Ja,
das nervt mich auch. Die schwimmen, die waren ganz im Wasser. Fun Fact, damals war die Erde noch komplett Wasser und die muss auch eher schwimmen. Aber nicht aus eigenem Antrieb, sondern die mussten so auf sie hatten also Hautsegel und mussten so auf Baumstämmen balancieren. Gibt es surfende Tiere, so Hautsegeln? Segeltier? Ich weiß es gar nicht. Es gibt ja so Hörnchen, die so Hautlappen haben zwischen Beinen und Armen. Flughörnchen, ja, ja. Flörnchen, die dann so durch die Gegend gleiten, die dann so durch die Gegend fliegen. Auch nicht schlecht eigentlich, oder? Super cool, rasend rum. Dass sich die mal treffen, so ein normales Hörnchen und ein Flughörnchen sagen kann, ich bin genau wie du, aber ich kann fliegen. Aber ich habe dieses Major Asset noch. Was hast du für ein Major Asset? Ich habe ein Päum. Ich vergesse manchmal Nüsse und dann werden daraus Bäume. Oh, wie niedlich, aber kannst du das? Everybody got savage! Viva Las Vegas! Fliegt so rum mit so einem Gatorblaster. Vor allem steht vor, die würden sich anfreunden und dann sagen, alles klar, dann gehen wir jetzt ins Kino und einer und der andere läuft da hin. Ja, die Eichhörnchen, jeder weiß, wie Eichhörnchen gehen. Jeder kennt es, diese stöhnenden, gemächlichen Tiere. Wart doch mal! Schleppen den diesen langen, buschigen Schwanz so im Dreck hinter sich her. Jeder kennt es. Jetzt ist er dreckig geworden. Schwingt ihn so über die Schulter. Glaubst du denn, dass die einfach fliegen können? Nein. Die müssen lange hochklettern auf Bäume. Die nehmen richtig viel Anlauf, so wie Super Mario. Und dann ... Nee, die können maximal von Klippen springen. Das sind im Prinzip, ich glaube, die sind leicht uncooler als richtige Eichhörnchen. Weil die immer wieder hochklettern müssen. Nein, weil die, ja, erstens das und zweitens, weil die wie so diese Männchen sind mit diesen Flug, äh, ja, diesen Anzügen, diesen Flying Suits. Das ist sehr weit hergeholt.
Flughörnchen ist wie ein Mensch in so einem Fluganzug, wo Arme und Beine mit einer Flugfläche verbunden sind.
Genau.
Also, Stefan, du kannst mir echt viel erzählen, aber der Vergleich ist jetzt wirklich so an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Nein, weil, und die können ja auch nicht fliegen einfach so. Die müssen auf dafür speziell vorgesehenen, grossen Bergen stehen und drunter springen. Und genau sind diese Flughörnchen nämlich auch. Und sonst haben die einfach dieses nervigen Hautlappen, zerren die hinter sich lang. Meinst du, die treffen sich manchmal, wenn der Mensch kurz davor ist, abzuspringen und daneben so eine ganze Reihe von diesen Flughörnchen und man nickt sich so zu. Ja, wir sehen uns unten. So, jetzt hat er wieder geschäftlich seine Maus. Kurz wieder beenden, sonst haben wir die ganze Zeit die Geräusche. Um das ganz kurz abzuschließen, weil wahrscheinlich viele von den Hörern jetzt schon Mails ausgestattet haben, dass du mich so haben, wenn du hier deine steilen Thesen wieder anbringst, schon Mails aufgesetzt haben und die Feder schon befüllt haben mit Blauertinte, dann möchte ich kurz Stopp rufen, denn ich habe mir bereits ein Ersatzteil bestellt, das mittlerweile in der Packstation liegt und das ich selber einbauen werde, um meinen Laptop zu reparieren, denn ich weiß den Wert zu schätzen und ich lebe für Nachhaltigkeit und ich habe meinen Laptop schon mal einen Akku ausgetauscht und werde jetzt das sogenannte Flexkabel austauschen, das Plastatur und Trackpad verbindet mit irgendwas. Das ist die Tiefe. Geht das wieder irgendwas? Das ist die Tiefe deines Wissens. Ein YouTube-Video angeguckt. Mit irgendwas verbinden. Ja, ich habe ein YouTube-Video angeguckt und mehr weiß ich nicht. Das ist das vollständige Wissen, das ich habe. Das Gute ist eigentlich, dass wahrscheinlich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr hoch, dass es für jedes Problem, was auf einer Reise, auf einem Abenteuer auftauchen wird, es noch ein Video gibt, was dir das wiederum erklärt. Und dann habe ich das bei Amazon bestellt und dachte mir dann, weil das ist mein Traum, weil mein Laptop ist schon älter und der geht nicht mehr und ich glaube, der ist voller Staub. Und ich hätte so Lust und allein der Gedanke daran, der lässt mich jauchzen, den einmal aufzuschrauben. aufzuschrauben und dann hast du da ganz viel Staubballen überall. Und dann würde ich gerne mit so einer Dose Druckluft. Ja, Dose Druckluft. Wie genial ist es übrigens, Druckluft zu verkaufen. Genial, oder? Ja, finde ich genial. Es muss noch mal Wetter entstanden. Ich wette mit dir, dass du es nicht schaffst, Luft zu verkaufen. Hold my Luftdose, ich hole meine Luftpumpe. Richtig geil, voll gut. Das ist so, du rauchst was, was du schon hast, nur halt mehr in kleinem Raum, ist genial. Aber... Finde ich super, mach das mal. Stellt sich raus, ich bin ja großer Packstation-Liebhaber, es gibt aber gewisse Arten von Produkten, die kann man nicht in Packstationen bestellen, zum Beispiel Samen und im weitesten Sinne Nahrungsmittel wegen der Ratten, weil sonst die Ratten Einzug nehmen. Einhaltgebieten. Einhaltgebieten und das abfangen und die Postboten angreifen würden, falls sie wissen, oh, da ist die gemeine Postratte. Die Postratte, die in der Packstation liebt. Haben die damals im Mittelalter schon die Post verbreitet. Obwohl ich das auch ne... Ich würde das aber auch ne niedliche Serie finden. Ratten, die in der Packstation leben. Und jeder hat ne eigene Haustür. Jeder hat ne eigene Klappe, genau. Und dann hier Frau Oppenhofer von der A8. Oh, jetzt! Oh, jetzt da unten! Hast du schon gehört? Was denn?
Bei Harry ist ein neues Paket angekommen. Nein, was ist denn gekommen? Samen oder Kabel? Nein, wir wissen es ja noch nicht. Sollen wir mal hingehen? Ja, lass uns hingehen. Flughörnchen vorbei. Ah, die sagt, ich hasse die. Wir mischen die ganze Nachbarschaft auf. Hey, Harry, ich habe gehört. Dem muss man Einhalt gebieten, eh sie hier einzugeben. Hey, Harry, wir haben gehört, dass du ein Paket.
Was? Nein!
Aus sicherer Quelle habe ich gehört, dass du ein Paket bekommen hast.
Was denn für eine Quelle? Hat das wieder Susel dir gesagt, oder was?
Nee, lass es mal hier rein.
Oh, jetzt dann!
Psst, Frau Obenhofer ist wieder wütend.
Oh, jetzt!
Nee, zeig mir dein Paket, Harry.
Okay, Mann, aber sag's keinem weiter.
Nee, ich sag's keinem weiter versprochen.
Guck mal, was hier drin ist.
Druckluftdose.
Nein, du hast es wirklich geschafft?
Ja, natürlich, Mann.
Natürlich, warte mal.
Jetzt bin ich dir die Wettschulden schuldig.
Fünf Samen! Ende. Aber ich finde, als Pilot klappt das schon. Als Pilot klappt das schon. Ja, besonders das Ende, wo Harry ihn mit grossen Augen anguckt und ich weiß, dass er sagen soll. Sechs Sekunden Stille vor dem Absprach. Ja, versendet sich. Es wird in jedem Film enden mit so einem, okay, wir haben es geschafft. Es versendet sich. Ich finde manchmal, passender Satz, es versendet sich auch nicht mehr, weil nein auch bei so vielen, damals haben wir so viele gute Arbeitssketsche geschrieben. Und auch mal ein, wo dann immer gesagt, das versendet sich, aber es war so schlecht, dass man, nein, das ist einfach, das wird nicht versenden. Das ist einfach da, das ist immer noch da. Hat bei The Room, beim Film The Room auch jemand gesagt, das versendet sich. Und jetzt ist es so, guck, wie schlecht dieser Film ist, so ein Kult, schlechter Film, hat sich nicht versendet. Aber genau, das ist ja eine Serie gesponsert von der DHL, die den Kindern schon früh klar machen sollen, warum man gewisse Dinge nicht in die Parkstation liefern soll. Dass Ratten getötet gehören. Ja, wir sind ja liebenswert. Wie bei Ratatouille oder eher nicht? Nicht ganz so liebenswert. Wir haben uns gedacht, Ratatouille minus 20%. Aber auch nicht so schlimm wie die Heuschrecken bei das Grosse Krabbel. Nein, nein, nein. Irgendwas in der netten Mitte dazwischen. Denn es ist tatsächlich so, man kann keine Druckluftdosen in Parkstationen bestellen. Und jetzt alle. Man kann keine Druckluftdosen in Packstation bestellen. Und jetzt alle. Man kann keine Druckluftdosen in Packstation bestellen. Man kann keine Druckluftdosen in Packstation bestellen. Man kann keine Druckluftdosen in Packstation bestellen. Und das ist nämlich mein Lifehack der Woche, des Tages für euch, für Sonntag, dass man keine Druckluftdosen in Packstation bestellen kann. Ja, das, oh Gott, was mache ich denn jetzt? Florian, hier, sag mir, was ich machen soll. Wie kann ich mein Leben denn jetzt noch vernünftig leben? Ja, das heißt, mein Traum, wenn ich jetzt eh schon mal meine alte Möhre aufschreibe, mein Laptop jetzt auch nochmal schön durchzupusten, hat sich in Luft aufgelöst. So, und das heißt, ich kann jetzt, ich habe jetzt echt überlegt, wie kann ich mir selber eine Art Druckluftdose bauen, also weil, du siehst, ich stecke da mitten im Gedankenprozess drin, aber eigentlich geht es ja nur um Verdichtung, du musst ja irgendwie, also, es geht prinzipiell um Verdichtung, ichiell um Verdichtung. Angenommen, ich puste in den Trichter. Ich puste in den breiten Teil eines Trichters. Dann wird ja die Luft nicht beschleunigt zumindest. Ja, das schon vielleicht. Die wird schon ein bisschen komprimiert. Wie funktioniert denn sonst sowas? Das ist mein Argument. Das ist eine Frage.
Wie funktioniert denn sonst sowas?
Ja, kannst du die Frage präzisieren?
Wie sieht die Fabrik aus, in der diese Druckluftdosen hergestellt werden?
Das ist eine riesige Fabrik, dann ist eine kleinere Fabrik daneben, noch eine kleinere Fabrik daneben und eine kleinere Fabrik daneben.
Dazwischen ist ein Rohr und der Rest ist Geschichte.
Oder die haben einfach eine riesige Druckluftdose
und füllen die in kleine Dosen um.
Und dann fragt man die, aber wo kommt die grosse Druckluftdose her?
Wir können, fragt diese, fragt die wieder.
Und dann zeigen sie auf so ein grosses Schild.
Genau.
Fragt niemals, wo die grosse Luftdose herkommt. Ja, also das heißt, ich habe jetzt überlegt, mein Problem ist ja Feuchtigkeit. Und ich dachte mir immer, wenn der menschliche Atem im Spiel ist, dann ist auch Feuchtigkeit im Spiel. Das heißt, ich habe überlegt, kann ich mir irgendeine Art, ich bräuchte so eine Art Zisterne. Das denke ich mir auch häufig. Ich habe einfach mal, mein Gehirn hat einfach mal irgendein Wort rausgehauen. Wurde kenne ich nochmal Zisterne? Das ist irgendwas Römisches, glaube ich. Ja, wie das Aquädukt. Aber was genau? Hängt eine Zisterne grob mit einem Aquädukt zusammen? Nee. Wird denn das Zisterne gebadet? Nein, das ist eine Therme. Ja, ist sie in Limonade drin? Nee, das ist Zitrone, Entschuldigung. Ach so, isotonisch. Nee, was ich meinte, ist ein ... Wie heißen die, wenn du eine Esse hast und da die Glut ... Eine was? Eine Esse. Mir fehlen zu viele Pokabeln. Das wird nie keinen Spaß machen, einfach Wörter zu sagen. Einfach Wörter. Nein, ich rede von einer Schmiede, wo heiße Luft, also jetzt aber, wenn du was heiß machen willst, dann nimmst du Kohle und pumpst da ganz viel Luft rein. Und da gibt es den Blasebike. So, sowas brauche ich. Ich brauche einen Blasebalg. Aber wo kriegt man denn heute noch einen guten Blasebalg her? Luftpumpe? Habe ich nicht. Hol doch einfach eine Druckluftpumpe und bestell die zu dir. Was hältst du davon? Dann soll ich jetzt den Laptop offen halten, bis die ankommt, oder was? Das ist wie eine Operation im offenen Herzen, man kann es auch nicht so lange offen halten. Ja, der Herr Doktor ist jetzt kurz weggegangen, er meinte, er kommt gleich wieder, aber wir haben jetzt mal auf den Parkplatz geguckt und sein Auto ist nicht mehr da. Jetzt kommt der nächste Chirurg leider erst am Montag, das heißt, wir müssen jetzt leider ihren Brustkorb bis Montag leider offen halten. Der Grund, warum ich nichts sage in diesem Sketch ist, der Grund, warum die Szene gerade nicht vorangeht, ist, ich bin unter Narkose. Ich bin Narkose, kann nicht sagen. Charakter-Actor Stefan Tiense nimmt seine Rolle ernst. Sorry, die Belehrung erfolgt mit einem Patienten, der nicht bei Bewusstsein ist. Er sitzt da, piep, piep, aber der Brustkorb ist offen. Dann hätte ich vielleicht klarer machen müssen, wo die Szene beginnt. Ich dachte, die Szene beginnt, wenn er aufwacht und zu Recht die Frage stellt, Entschuldigung, warum ist mein Brustkorb noch offen? Warum ist denn mein Brustkorb klaffend weit offen? Ja. Dann hätte die Szene stattgefunden. Aber gut, das ist jetzt auch erledigt. Habe mich gegen entschieden, sorry. Naja, das heißt, wir haben jetzt leider nur drei ... Aber ich freue mich sehr auf deine Erlebnisse, wie du mit deinem Laptop zurande gekommen bist. Ich hoffe sehr, dass das funktioniert, weil wenn nicht, wirst du mich und werden vielleicht andere mich im ICE sitzend sehen, als erbärmlichstes Bild, das sie seit langem gesehen haben, ein junger Herr vor einem Laptop mit einer riesigen Tastatur und Maus daran angeschlossen, im ICE, dass du den trotzdem mitnimmst und deine ganze Peripherie auch mitschleppst,an habe ich nicht gedacht. Volle Peripherie, schön zwei Sitze am Sitz neben mir mit der Maus, Klickmaus. Peripherie, Zisterne, da ist wirklich alles dabei. Wir müssten eigentlich so Vokabelkarten dazulegen zu den Folgen, oder? Das sind immer so fünf Vokabelkarten pro Folge, pro Woche. Es gibt aber auch fantastische Wörter, die man zu selten benutzt. Moloch. Wie herrlich ist das Wort Moloch. Wir müssen eigentlich eine Hausaufgabe aufgeben. Hörer benutzt das Wort Moloch bis nächste Woche. In einer professionellen, beruflich professionellen E-Mail. Und wir bekommen den Screenshot. Genau, schickt uns den Screenshot. Jeder Hörer, sonst werdet ihr händisch von uns blockiert, über die Kanäle, wo ihr uns hört. Genau. Könnt ihr das nicht mehr hören. Alle Hörer werden blockiert. Die keine Mail schicken. Genau, die keine Mail mit einem Screenshot benutzt, das ist die Sprachhausaufgabe, das Podcast-Uvo-Sprachhausaufgabe benutzt das Wort Moloch in einem offiziellen Kontext. Ihr könnt es auch verbal machen, dann müsst ihr das aber mitschneiden. Dann müsst ihr das mitschneiden. Und dann müsst ihr... Die Sprache soll nicht sterben. Nein, wir können euch natürlich auch verzerren. Wenn ihr sagt, verzerrt, Verzerrung gewünscht. Bitte Verzerrung gewünscht, könnt ihr anklicken, Verzerrung gewünscht. Und dann werden wir euch verzerren. Das machen wir den ganzen Tag, wenn sein muss. Ich freue mich auf eure Einschichten. Vielen Dank, macht's wie Melissa, die sich an der Sendung beteiligt und uns ein bisschen Science-Fun-Facts bietet.
Ansonsten haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche.
Habt eine schöne Woche und ja.
Ich würd sagen, wir machen's wie das Flughörnchen.
Und rasen durch den Wald, bis wir irgendwann,
Batsch, gegen den Baumstamm fliegen.
Und einen abheben.